nothing could ever get in the way of my
love for Blake Shelton sexual love Adam
Levine sticking with his Blake Shelton
bromance if only for just a moment
he's lost enough seasons to now I feel I
feel like it's even too tough out a
little bit so I want people to know that
this actually like isn't just for TV
like they actually do have like a nice
little rivalry it's like it goes on
off-camera it's a okay team Adams newest
mentor Charlie puth stepping in to
defuse that feud on the upcoming season
of The Voice Adam cares about his team
and he wants to win and he's very
passionate about it even when these
cameras come off and I really don't like
Blake I'm trying to smooth that over is
it I don't like him he's a jerk but when
it comes to newbie coach John Legend's
that's a different story the easiest guy
to get along with on the planet absolute
greatest hope he wins if it's not if
it's not me you know I hope it's a john
is a much more extroverted person than
people realize John caught fire
you got some Christi in them the voice
returns to NBC on Monday February 25th
[Music]